Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Mustafa Çelik und ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistenz, als Stätig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, kurz zum Ablauf. Ich werde Ihnen so erst ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen
und danach werden wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen, okay?
Ja, ist okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Manfred Meyer.
Manfred Meyer.
Ja.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vornamen und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, der Vornamen lautet also M-A-N-F-R-E-D, Manfred.
Ja, 2.e ist W-E-M-I, ja.
2.e, ja, E-W-E.
2.e Buchstabe ist W-E-M-I, ja, Manfred.
Ja.
Und Meyer mit A-I und E, M-A-I-E-R, Meyer.
Okay, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Meyer?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
63. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Wann bin ich geboren?
1900.
Was ist es dann?
60, 5. Mai.
5. Mai, okay.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Meyer?
1 Meter 76.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 85 Kilogramm.
85 Kilogramm, okay.
Ja, was kann ich für Sie tun, Herr Meyer?
Also, ich habe seit ungefähr 3-4 Monaten immer wieder mal Bauchschmerzen.
Können Sie mir jetzt zeigen, wo die Schmerzen sind?
Also, so unterhalb des Nabels, so in dem Bereich, tut mir das immer wieder mal weh.
Unterhalb des Nabels, ja.
Zutragen diese Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nee, also manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, das ist mehr so im Rücken, mal ist es mehr vorne.
Es ist nicht so ganz eindeutig, aber ausstrahlen tun Sie nicht, nee.
Okay.
Haben diese Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen oder ich meine, sind diese Schmerzen attackartig?
Noch mal, ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Diese Schmerzen sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Ach so, also ich kann mich gar nicht mal dran erinnern, wie die zum ersten Mal waren, aber die kommen manchmal, die fangen so an, werden stärker und nach einer gewissen Zeit hören die dann wieder auf.
Okay.
Können Sie mir beschreiben den Charakter von Schmerzen?
Ich meine, sind Schmerzen eher dumpf, stehend, brennend oder dumpfer?
Nee, also ein dumpfer Schmerz, würde ich sagen.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder treten sie hin und wieder auf?
Also die kommen und gehen, aber wann die kommen, kann ich nicht absehen.
Also die kommen irgendwann, dann sind sie nach einer gewissen Zeit wieder weg und manchmal fangen die dann plötzlich wieder an.
Okay, das verstehe.
Hör auf, wiederkommen, hör auf, wiederkommen, ja?
Ja, aber nicht hintereinander, sondern sagen wir mal heute habe ich jetzt wieder Schmerzen gehabt und wenn die wieder weg sind, kann es sein, dass ich zwei, drei Tage keine Schmerzen habe.
Und dann sind die wieder da.
Okay.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf eines Kalafon bis von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichten Schmerzen und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Also ich würde sagen so ungefähr 6.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nee, das Einzige, was ich sagen kann, wenn ich so ein bisschen Stuhl dran habe, dann löst es so ein bisschen den Schmerz, außer ich den Eindruck.
Ja, das kann ich nicht sehr gut verstehen, ja, können Sie anders formulieren?
Also wenn ich auf Toilette muss, dann habe ich den Eindruck, dass die Schmerzen zunehmen. Stuhlgang.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich, danke schön.
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen verschlechter oder verbessert? Ich meine, es kann Essen sein oder Bewegung sein?
Nee, nicht, dass ich müsste. Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendein paar Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Also ich habe mal versucht mit Paracetamol, das hat aber nicht so geholfen, muss ich sagen.
In welcher Dosierung haben Sie diese Paracetamol eingenommen?
Das war einmal 500 Milligramm.
Okay. Haben Sie sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert oder verbessert?
Ich habe den Eindruck, die werden mehr.
Verschlechtert. Hatten Sie Unfall oder Verletzung in der Vergangenheit?
Nee, kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
Okay. Vor vier Monaten hatten Sie einiger Beschwerden, zum Beispiel letztes Jahr.
Wie gesagt, da habe ich das zum ersten Mal bemerkt. Da waren die Schmerzen aber nicht so stark gewesen.
Ich habe gemerkt, da ist was und das ist nicht so ganz normal, aber jetzt sind das noch starke Schmerzen.
Okay. Haben Sie Fibar, Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß oder Kaltenschweiß?
Nee, was ist Kaltenschweiß?
Kaltenschweiß bedeutet, wenn Sie eine Herausforderung haben.
Man hat Schweiß, aber das ist nicht zum Beispiel nach den Fußballspielen oder Reppensteigen.
Wenn man in Ruhe, in Ruhe zustand, aber man hat viele Schweiß.
Sie meinen Kaltschweiß?
Nee, Kaltenschweiß habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Kaltenschweiß? Ja, Kaltenschweiß.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nee, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Verstopfung, haben Sie Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Also der Stuhlgang ist so wechselhaft. Mal ist es so fest, mal ist es wässrig.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was so ganz richtig ist.
Wie war die Farbe von Stuhl?
Haben Sie irgendwelche ungewöhnliches bemerkt beim Stuhlgang?
Manchmal hatte ich den Eindruck, dass da vielleicht ein bisschen Blut mit dabei sein kann.
Ich kontrolliere es aber nicht.
Okay, das ist wichtig für uns.
Wann haben Sie das Blut gesehen im Stuhl?
Wann war das?
Oder manchmal sehen Sie?
Also ich kontrolliere es nicht immer.
Aber ich hatte den Eindruck vor vier Wochen, dass da was Rotes auch mit dabei war.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen, Herr Meier?
Nee, Probleme beim Wasserlassen natürlich nicht.
Okay, das ist gut. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
In der letzten Seite.
Okay, da habe ich kein Problem mit.
In der letzten Seite, haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Weder noch.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Nee, habe ich nie gedacht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nee, auch nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme bei der Atmung?
Atmen Probleme auch nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Bewusstsein verloren?
Oder war Ihnen Schwarz vor Augen?
Nee, nee, nie gehabt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Nee, Zuckerkrank bin ich nicht.
Aber mein Blutdruck ist nur leicht erhöht.
Ein Hausarzt hat mir vor zwei Jahren so eine Tablette gegeben.
Welche Tablette?
Können Sie erinnern daran?
Ich glaube, Ramipril war es.
Ramipril, ja.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie dieser Medikamente ein?
Das ist eine Tablette, glaube ich, fünf Millikamern oder so.
Okay.
Morgens nehmen Sie diese Tablette ein, oder?
Ja, morgens.
Sonst nehmen Sie keinen Medikament.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen etwas?
Oder Unfallträglichkeiten?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Meier?
Bitte?
Rauchen Sie.
Ob ich rauche?
Nee, ich habe nie geraucht.
Dann zählt es vielleicht einmal oder zweimal im Jahr.
Oh, das ist gut.
Ja.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Nee, Erfahrungen betrogen.
In der Familie gibt es Erkrankungen
oder Telefon-Krebs?
Wenn Sie mich so fragen,
ich glaube, mein Großvater hatte Diktarmkrebs.
Diktarmkrebs, okay.
Und an diese Krankheit ist er gestorben?
Ich glaube, ja.
Das war ja damals noch nicht so ganz geklärt.
Das war nach dem Krieg, so in den 50er Jahren.
Da ist er damals gestorben.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nee, ich wurde ja noch nie operiert.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Gegen was meinen Sie denn?
Gegen Corona zum Beispiel.
Gegen Corona bin ich geimpft.
Okay.
War Ihnen im Ausland in der letzten Zeit?
Im Ausland war ich vor einem Jahr im Urlaub.
Im einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr.
Was machen Sie, Belfry Harmaier?
Ich war bisher als Maschineningenieur tätig,
aber jetzt bin ich kurz vor der Pension.
Ja.
Lieben Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Frau?
Nein, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Das ist gut.
Haben Sie viel Stress im Leben?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay, jetzt.
Ich glaube, dass ich als Belfry Harmaier
alle wichtige Fragen gestellt habe.
Ich möchte Ihnen erklären, was ich machen werde.
Zuerst.
Ich untersuche Sie.
Zuerst körperlich und dann mit Ultraschall.
Abdomen Ultraschall.
Und ich überprüfe Ihre Vitalparameter.
Also meine Ihre Atemfrequenz,
Blutdruck und Pörpertemperatur.
Außerdem Sauerstoffsättigung überprüfe ich.
Und dann ich nehme Blut ab für weitere Labordiagnostik.
Und ich werde Sie Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Außerdem, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Blut im Stuhl gesehen haben.
Deswegen brauchen wir eine Stuhlprobe zu diagnostikieren.
Weil normalerweise Blut im Stuhl ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Und das ist eine gute Anseite für richtige Diagnose.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, nein, wie lange muss ich denn im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, gute Frage.
Ich werde schnell alles erledigen.
Aber es kann dauert ein paar Stunden.
Aber ich muss so, ja, das was sagt.
Ein paar Stunden.
Ich muss so, ich muss so, ich muss so, ich muss so.
Ich muss nicht hier bleiben, nicht über Nacht.
Nach dem Untersuchung Labordiagnostik, ich werde informieren Sie.
Aber jetzt, ich weiß nicht, aber nach dem Labordiagnostik wissen wir mehr.
Okay, na gut, dann warten wir mal ab.
Alles klar, einverstanden.
Okay, vielen Dank, ja, gute Westerung.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sind Sie gegen diese Beschwerden bei einem Arzt schon gewesen?
Nein, nein.
In dieser Zeit fühlen Sie sich müde oder schlapp?
Etwas.
So in letzter Zeit habe ich den Eindruck, ich bin so ein bisschen müde.
Also nicht mal so Leistungsfähigkeit.
Etwas schwindelig?
Warum schwindel habe ich nicht, nein.
Danke.
Das habe ich vergessen, diese Frage.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut oder Augen,
die Hörfarbung haben, Sie haben Sie,
dass Sie Ihre Haut oder Augen irgendwie auf der Hörfarbung
haben.
Welche Hörfarbung haben Sie?
Gebt nicht, geworden.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Kollege, ich habe eine Frage.
Können wir als Arzt-Arzt-Geschiebte anfangen?
Können wir?
Ein Moment.
Ja.
Ich möchte, dass Sie meistens nach dem Essen sind,
oder vor dem Essen sind aufgeklärt, Herr Kollege.
Meistens immer, ungefähr eine Stunde nach dem Essen.
Nach dem Essen.
Haben Sie öfter so einen Sohles aufgestoßen,
Belehungen bemerkt?
Belehungen, ja, aber keinen Aufstoßen, kein Sohle aufstoßen.
Haben Sie, hat sich Ihre Gewicht in der Lester Zeit
merklich verändert?
Noch mal bitte.
Hat sich Ihre Gewicht in der Lester Zeit
merklich verändert?
Gewichtsveränderung, nein, nein, hatte ich nicht.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit schraubiert.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten. Darf ich ihn vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Meine Patientin ist Manfred Meyer.
Er ist 63 Jahre alt und 1 Meter, 76 groß
und 85 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Meyer hat sich wegen seit 3-4 Monaten bestehende Bauchschmerzen
im Unterhalt des Nabels vorgestellt.
Gewichtsveränderung unter dem Nabel, das heißt?
Fachbegriffe weiß ich nicht, das kann nicht.
Unter Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, okay.
Bischmerzen seien dummartig und wellenformig.
Und Bischmerzen hat keine Ausstrahlung.
Und er hat dagegen gelegentlich Parasythomal eingenommen.
Im Laufe der Zeit berichtet, der Patient berichtete,
dass die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit sich verschlechtert haben.
Und begreiten Sie sich nicht zu.
Seit 3-4 Monaten.
Im Ma Schmerzen da oder?
Ja, ich habe so festgegnt, Sie haben wellenformig Schmerzen.
Sie haben Schmerzattake, aber wiederkommt.
Es gibt keine Regel.
Manchmal sind plötzlich die Schmerzen angefangen.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, wenn man das Fachmensch sagen will,
muss es heißen, rezipierende Unterbauchschmerzen.
Oder auf Deutsch wiederholende Unterbauchschmerzen,
die eine gewisse Zeit anhalten und wieder abklingen.
Er hat rezipierende Unterbauchschmerzen.
Im Laufe der Zeit haben sich die Schmerzen verschlechtert?
Nein, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Schmerzen verschlechtern sich nicht,
sondern Schmerzen haben zukernommen.
Schmerz-Zunahme sagt man.
Schmerzen verschlechtern sich nicht.
Schmerz-Interest.
Schmerzen nehmen zu.
Ja, prokedient, kann man auch sagen.
Aber im Deutschen sagt man Schmerz-Zunahme.
Die Schmerzen haben in den letzten Monaten zugenommen.
Als Attacken kommen, zum Beispiel, möglich.
Das kann man so nicht sagen.
Das sind keine Attackenschmerzen,
sondern das sind so einschleichende Schmerzen,
die langsam so zunehmen und dann so wieder abklingen.
keine Attacken. Attacken sind, wenn jemand so kollegatig plötzlich von null auf 100 Schmerzen bekommt und sich vor Schmerzen krümmt.
Das würde ich als Attacker bezeichnen. Aber oder wenn jemand irgendwie eine Trigemusneuralgie oder so im Gesicht bekommt,
das ist eine Schmerzattacke, wo man dann sagt, er hält die Schmerzen nicht aus. Aber das, was dieser Mensch angebt,
das sind mehr so rezitivierende, mittelmäßige Schmerzen, so fünf bis sechs.
Okay.
Thank you.
Außer dem klackte er, klackte meinem Patienten über Hematokäsia. Das war seit vier Wochen.
Aber meine Patient ist nicht sicher, weil er kontrolliert ihre Stuhl nicht regelmäßig.
Ja, sonst sagen sie, vor vier Wochen hat er einmal im Stuhl Blut Beimengungen bemerkt.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, in Kontinass, Stuhl in Kontinass, richtig?
Nee, nee, kein Stuhl in Kontinass.
Er hat, ja, als Auslöser hat er...
Er hat nur ein bisschen Blut im Stuhl bemerkt, aber kein Stuhl in Kontinass.
Ja, ja.
Und er hat Gullutok Arterellhypertoni und dagegen nimmt er Rami Pril jeden Tag morgens ein.
Und er hat keine Fieber oder Nachtschweiß oder Kaltschweiß.
Er raucht nicht und gelegentlich trinkt Alkohol.
Und das ist mir wichtig.
Seine Großvater hat darm Kolonkarcinom und wahrscheinlich an diese Krankheit gestorben.
Mein Internet ist...
Hallo?
Ja.
Ja, Herma hat berichtet, dass ihr Großvater an Kolonkarcinom gestorben ist.
Das finde ich wichtig, weil genetische Anlagung ist wichtig für meine Diagnose.
Und er ist im Rente.
Diese Teil habe ich nicht sehr gut verstanden.
Er ist Ingenieur, aber in Pension steht.
Herr Oberhörst, weiß ich nicht genau.
Pension.
Pension? Ja, das Rente, ja.
Rente.
Ja, ja, ja.
Rente, sagt man.
Okay.
Und er ist verheiratet und wohnt mit ihrer Frau.
Mit seiner Frau.
Mit seiner Frau, ja, mit seiner Frau.
Und ja, das war es.
Anonystische Aufgaben deuten auf Kolonkarcinom hin.
Und für diese Diagnose erhärten würde ich...
Einsel Diagnosis.
Ja, differenzial Diagnosis.
Überlege ich Kolonpoliposis.
Und Ulsterativkollekt, vielleicht.
Ja.
Und Crohn, Morbus Crohn.
Ja, was kann es noch sein?
Kann ich sagen.
Ja.
Wenn wir einfach denken, Hemorrhoids sein.
Hemorrhoids auch sein.
Hemorrhoids, könnte auch sein.
Ja, was noch?
Ja, Infektions, Infektions, Prozess kann sein.
Zum Beispiel, Armebeer oder...
Ja, kann auch sein, aber das Gängigste, was man da im Darm
meistens immer so antrifft, im Dickdarm.
Ja.
Ulsterativkollekt, habe ich gesagt, aber noch...
Ja, ja, Divertikulitis.
Ja, sehr gut.
Divertikulitis sein, was dieser Mensch hat, weil das macht
manchen Leuten noch extrem stark Beschmerzen immer wieder.
Ja.
Gut.
Okay.
Das war es von Ihrer Seite, oder machen Sie noch was weiter?
Ich möchte etwas erzählen, wenn Sie möchten.
Ja.
Ich würde für labordiagnostisch,
blutbild, Entsündung, Parameter,
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte
und ein paar Tumormarker kontrollieren.
Aber Tumormarker weiß ich nicht genau.
Ja, aber man darf Tumormarker nicht kontrollieren,
wenn man keine Tumalkrankung hat.
Aber wir haben...
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, also Sie dürfen Tumormarker nur kontrollieren,
wenn Sie eine Tumorekrankung festgestellt haben.
Okay, verstehe.
Aber Sie dürfen nicht mit Tumormarker fahren,
denn also auf die Suche gehen, das geht nicht.
Okay, verstehe.
Und in Schreck müssen Sie...
Ja, weil das ist nicht zulässig.
Okay.
Ich würde Schutulintersuchung machen,
wenn Sie einen Probe haben und dann zum Labor schicken.
Ja, und ja...
Wie nennt man diesen Test?
Ja, ich glaube, FOP, Fetzal-Okult-Bullut-Test, FOPT.
Ja, E-FOPT, ne?
Ja.
Früher hat man den Hem-Okult-Test bezeichnet.
Das müssen Sie schon so sagen.
Sie müssen schon wissen, wie so was funktioniert.
Und was das auch ist.
Was versucht man damit nachzuweisen?
Das verstehe ich nicht gut.
Wofür ist dieser Test?
Ja, für Blut im Stuhl.
Das kann beweisen.
Wir können mit diesem Test beweisen, ob es Blut im Stuhl gibt.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Man will schauen, ob Blut im Stuhl vorhanden ist.
Ja, das ist auch so ne Sache.
Hier in Deutschland sagt man, wenn jemand in der Klinik ist,
wo auch eine Endoskopie gemacht werden kann,
dann brauche ich keinen Stuhltest.
Dann mache ich gleich eine Kuloskopie, weil das kostet Zeit.
Ja.
Wenn ich woanders bin,
weil es geht schneller,
weil Sie machen ein Stuhltest und der wird nicht positiv sein.
Wenn jemand schon in der Klinik ist, dann machen Sie gleich eine Kuloskopie.
Und dann nicht brauchen wir Kuloskopie?
Ne, wenn man E-Forb-Test positiv hat,
dann müssen Sie den sowieso Kuloskopieren.
Dann können Sie auch gleich Kuloskopieren.
Wenn der Patient sagt, der hat Blut im Stuhl bemerkt,
eine Sache haben Sie vergessen, was müssen Sie nämlich machen?
Sie müssen den man rektal, digital untersuchen.
Ja, ja.
Und wenn da Blut am Fingerling ist, dann brauchen Sie keinen E-Forb-Test.
Ja, natürlich.
Weil wir schon beweisen, ja, deswegen.
Ja, richtig.
Das ist dann schon gewesen.
Jetzt haben Sie den Nachweis, Sie schicken keinen E-Forb-Test
und Sie melden den für eine Kuloskopie an.
Für diese Patienten,
nächsten Schritt würde ich eine Kuloskopie planen.
Ja.
Und ich werde ein Konsul zur Gastroenterologie schreiben.
Ja, Sie melden, je nachdem, wenn er in der Notaufnahme ist,
dann nehmen Sie den in die Gastroenterologie auf.
Was machen Sie dann damit dem?
Den können Sie gleich aufklären, direkt für eine Kuloskopie aufklären.
Ah, das ist gut, ja.
Natürlich, das geht anders.
Ja, das geht schneller.
Sie müssen immer sehr pragmatisch vorgehen
und so schnell wie möglich die Diagnostik abschließen,
damit nicht viel Zeit verloren geht.
Wenn Sie den Eindruck haben, der hat Blut im Stuhl,
Sie möchten den Kuloskopieren, dann klären Sie den ganz schnell auf.
Sie melden den für die Kuloskopie an und dann nehmen Sie noch die Station.
Aber bevor Sie so weit sind, in der Notaufnahme noch,
jetzt haben Sie den untersucht, Sie haben Blut im Stuhl bemerkt,
jetzt müssen Sie noch einen Rundumpaket machen.
Sie müssen das Labor noch anschauen.
Weil er hat gesagt, er fühlt sich nicht gut,
er fühlt sich ein bisschen schlapp in letzter Zeit.
Wonach müssen Sie noch schauen?
Ja, wir müssen eine Miere kontrollieren.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das heißt, Sie müssen sich das Blutbild angucken.
Wenn er sehr viel Blut verloren hat,
er hat gesagt, er kontrolliert seinen Stuhlgang nicht so häufig.
Und da kann viel Blut abgegangen sein.
Und jetzt nehmen Sie eine Blutbildkontrolle ab
und Sie sehen, der Hormoglobin-Wert,
der liegt nur bei 7,5.
7,5, ja, das ist sehr viel erniedrigt.
Das ist die Mikrosteranämie, glaube ich,
weil wir Blut geben müssen.
Die Patienten, sieben ist Grenze.
Ich weiß nicht, Hypokrom-Mikrosteranämie.
Erst einmal, warum?
Weil es gibt ...
Weil von Hypokrom können Sie nur reden,
wenn Sie eine Mikro-Zutere-Anämie
im Differenzerr-Blutbild oder im Glutbild sehen würden.
Da müssen Sie sich den MTV angucken.
Aber davon war ja momentan gar nicht der Rede.
Es wird sicherlich eine Mikro-Zutere-Eisenmangel-Anämie werden.
Keine Frage.
Aber Sie dürfen nicht direkt mit einer Mikro-Zutere-Anämie
gleich rauskommen.
Was Sie sagen können, der Mann hat eine Anämie.
Punkt.
Und wenn Sie so jemanden in die Koloskopie schicken wollen,
dann sollten Sie zusehen,
dass es nicht so gut geht.
Sie müssen Kreuzblut abnehmen.
Sie müssen eine Konserve für den Mann bestellen.
Dass der eine Konserve Retrozitten bekommt,
damit die Koloskopie ohne Probleme ablaufen kann.
Und was machen Sie noch?
Wenn Sie jemanden in den Endoskopie schicken dürfen,
dürfen Sie nie vergessen,
Sie müssen solchen Leuten immer einen großlumigen Zugang legen.
Ich lege...
Ja, hören Sie mich?
Ja, ja, ich lege einen großen, wenigen Zugang ein.
Ich lege, ja, okay.
Für Betäubung und für...
Ich würde mal das Internet machen.
Aber echt Probleme.
Hör ich,
wenn Sie sich das an den
Internet machen,
bitte ich.
Herr Wetz?
Ich habe schon einen großen Zugang eingelegt.
Ja, großen Zugang haben Sie gelegen, sehr gut.
Okay?
Und dann nehmen Sie den Patienten auf die Station auf.
Und der wird dann dementsprechend koloskopiert.
Jawoll.
Was können Sie noch machen? Wenn Sie den noch in der Notaufnahme haben, haben Sie einen ganz am Anfang gesagt,
ja, es ist zwar klar, dass der eine Dickdarm-Spiegelung eine Polyspopie braucht, aber Sie können auch gleich
eine Ultraschall-Untersuchung vom Bauch machen. Sie können gucken, ob die Leber in Ordnung ist,
ob was anderes noch zu sehen ist oder nicht.
Das war es von Ihrer Seite? Ja, es kommt darauf an, wie Sie sagen.
Gut, und wie gehen Sie jetzt mit dem Vorn nehmen wir mal an. Jetzt hat man bei dem tatsächlich einen Tumor im
Sigma-Bereich gesehen. Da tut es ihm auch weh. Das passt dann auch. In der Spiegelung sagt der Gastroenterologe,
er sieht da einen großen, teilweise ulzerierten Tumor im Sigma-Bereich.
Was machen wir jetzt mit dem auf Station?
Ja, wir müssen den Grade von Tumor machen. Ich meine, wir müssen untersuchen, ob es eine Lymphknoten oder
Metastase haben. Wir müssen diese Grading-System erledigen.
Das ist aber kein Grading, was Sie sagen.
Ja, deswegen habe ich Englisch.
Aber das, was Sie schildern, das nennt man Staging und nicht Grading.
Problem ist nicht Englisch.
Staging ist mehr oder weniger ein Stadium festlegen.
Wir müssen schauen, ob das eine lokalisierte Erkrankung ist oder ob das eine metastasierte Erkrankung ist.
Grading bedeutet malin oder benin oder malin-Degrees.
Nein, ein Teilung ist gleich ein Teilung der...
Grading bezeichnet einfach nur der Einteilung, wie weit der Tumor differenziert ist oder enddifferenziert ist.
Wenn Sie von G0, G1 bis G3 gehen, je mehr Differenzierte der Tumor ist, desto langsamer wächst ein Tumor.
Das nennt man Grading, G1, G2, G3. Aber ein Staging sagt, ob jemand Metastasen hat oder Lymphknotenvergrößerung hat oder nicht.
Das heißt, wer macht das Staging? Wer macht das Grading, wenn Sie so fragen?
Ja, Grading macht Pathologen, nach meiner Meinung.
Z.B. macht General-Hirurgin in diesem Fall.
Nein, nicht Hirurg.
Und Onkologen?
Nein, nein, auch nicht.
Er macht Radio-Loggen.
Der Radio-Loggen macht ein CT, Torax und Abdomen.
Und dann sagt er am Ende, er sieht einen lokalisierten Tumor im Sigma-Bereich,
vielleicht maximal in der Umgebung, ein, zwei vergrößerte Lymphknoten.
Und sonst sieht er keine Oszeren-Metastasen, er sieht keine pulmonalen Metastasen und er sieht keine hepatischen Metastasen.
So, mehr kann man nicht erstmal gar nicht sagen, den endgültigen Tumorformel,
das sagt uns der Hirurg, da haben Sie Recht.
Aber das Staging sagt erstmal nur, ob jemand Metastasen hat oder nicht.
Okay, verstehe.
In diesem Fall, keine Metastasen, nur ein paar lokale Lymphknoten,
dann so schnell wie möglich, sollen diese Patienten operiert werden.
Nein, sehr gut.
Aber erstmal, Herr Kollege, preoperativ, pre-adjuvant Therapie-Müssung?
Keine Metastas.
Beim Kolonkarzinom macht man keine neo-adjuvante Chemotherapie.
Beim Rektum ist das was anderes, aber beim Kolonkarzinom, der nicht, ich sage mal, jetzt metastasiert ist,
vielleicht ein, zwei Lebermetastasen gesetzt hat, das wird nicht neo-adjuvant chemotherapiert.
Kolonkarzinom, was nicht metastasiert ist, wird sofort operiert.
Vor allem bei jungen Leuten, bei Älteren tut man sich da so ein bisschen schwer,
aber 60 Jahre, 70 Jahre, 75 Jahre bis zu diesem Alter, 80 Jahre, da operieren die Chirurgen direkt.
Und dann werden wir adjuvant chemotherapiert, nicht neo-adjuvant.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, klar.
Nach der Operation, die Grenze von chirurgischer Rand sind sauer ist,
müssen wir immer noch adjuvant Chemotherapie oder Adjuvant Therapie machen?
Radiotherapie beim Sigma oder Kolonkarzinom gar nicht.
Aber Chemotherapie nur in ganz bestimmten Fällen, unter anderem, wenn Lymphknoten befallen sind.
Da reicht ein Lymphknoten aus, damit man eine adjuvant Chemotherapie machen muss.
Oder es gibt sogenannte Risikofaktoren.
Was sind Risikofaktoren, wenn der Tumor zum Beispiel ein T4 Tumor, die Sero sei irgendwie durchschritten hat
oder der Tumor während der Operation im Bauchraum, im Peritoneum zerfallen ist,
also ein Tumor Einriss gegeben hat.
Das sind Risikosituationen, wo man dann sagt, der braucht auch eine adjuvant Chemotherapie.
Aber ein Tumor, der nur in der Darmwand ist und wo keine Lymphknoten befallen sind,
der kriegt auch keine adjuvant Chemotherapie, sondern nur Nachsorge.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Also wichtig ist, dass man sauber arbeitet, Schritt für Schritt arbeitet.
Und wenn man dann das Staging vernünftig gemacht hat, dann müssen Sie ein chirurgisches Konzil aufstellen.
Dann sagen Sie, lieber Chirurg, ich habe hier einen Patienten, 60 Jahre oder 63 Jahre alt, da ist koloskopisch ein Kulonkarzinom festgestellt worden.
Dann will er sagen, was ist das denn für ein Tumor, ein Adenocarzinom oder ein anerplastisches Karzinom?
Das wird über 99 Prozent ein Adenocarzinom sein.
Wenn Sie wollen, können Sie auch das Grating nennen, ob das jetzt ein G2 oder G3 ist oder G1, können Sie sich dann aussuchen.
Und dann sagen Sie, verdacht auf lokale Lymphknotenmetastasen, aber keine Fernmetastasen.
Und der Chirurg entscheidet dann, wenn er den operieren will.
Im größeren Häusern gibt es mittlerweile noch ein Gremium, was vorher auch noch eingeschaltet wird.
Das ist der Tumorboard.
Ist unsere Falle. Hepatikmetastase sind Fernmetastase, können wir sagen?
Ja, richtig. Lebermetastasen sind Fernmetastase.
Wobei man aber sagen muss, beim Kulonkarzinom ist die Situation ein bisschen anders.
Wenn man nur eine Lebermetastase hat oder zwei Lebermetastasen hat, kann man die auch raus operieren.
Manche Churgen machen das gleichzeitig.
Wenn sie den Darm operieren, manche sagen zweizeitig.
Das bedeutet, er ist den Darm operieren, dann kriegen die ihre Adjuvantichemotherapie
und erst nach hinein werden dann die Lebermetastasen entfernt.
Geht auch. Dankeschön.